[Musique]
dans la salle municipale toute proche
des festivités de la foire de bras panon
la prestigieuse commission de l'océan
indien organise son troisième comité de
pilotage sur le présent une réunion
technique avec des représentants de
chaque pays de la zone afin d'avancer
sur ce programme régional de sécurité
alimentaire et de nutrition l'avenir
commun passe sans doute par ce programme
alimentaire de sécurisation qui
permettrait dans ce bassin
indianocéanique de pouvoir mettre en
ordre de marche l'ensemble des
politiques agricoles que nous avons il
ne s'agit pas pour nous de concurrencer
les pays voisins ou de houe que les pays
voisins viennent faire de la concurrence
aux agriculteurs et aux productions
locales mais plutôt de trouver une
complémentarité le département chef de
file de la politique agricole du
territoire se projette ainsi sur
l'avenir avec ce projet d'opportunités
de production de transformation et de
consommation agroalimentaire dans lydia
océanie on est à l'ère de la
mondialisation et au contraire nous
agriculture on voit les habitudes de
consommation qu'ils arrêtent pas
d'évoluer et c'est vrai que nous mêmes
producteurs on est un peu perdu
on mange de plus en plus de pattes de de
céréales de pain et effectivement la
base de notre alimentation c'était le
riz demain ça peut encore évoluer avec
la malbouffe
donc effectivement et c'est là l'intérêt
de ce programme c'est pas un programme
qui se concentre uniquement sur les
aspects agricole il ya aussi un gros
volet que moi j'ai trouvé intéressant
c'est de d'éducation des consommateurs
pour vraiment qu'on se nourrissent mieux
et que c'est une question de santé
publique aussi une étude des chaînes de
valeur sur chaque denrée alimentaire des
pays de la zone permet de déterminer les
axes prioritaires car les situations
sont parfois curieux au local aux
éditions pour qu'ils
ce que nous n'existons pas observé nous
mangeons de la viande c'est pareil c'est
peut-être bien fini du brésil c'est là
dès sa part du continent'' amérique du
sud ce à travers toute la clarté que ça
freine toute l'afrique et sa rivalité
alimentaire et nutritionnelle constitué
cette année mémorable l'agriculture
depuis longtemps a toujours été de même
révélé vieux souverain des états et donc
quand on veut travailler dans la dignité
il faut toujours avoir la pudeur su ce
que nous faisons si nos champs delajoux
pour avoir l'appui des institutions
c'est pour essayer de répondre aux
nouveaux besoins des états parce
qu'elles sont des êtres accuse de
maisons de leur population
il n'y a pas de vrais échanges
économiques basés sur l'agriculture dans
la zone de l'océan indien
c'est un appel du pied et ben si nous
travaillons à l'intérieur
petit c haque grand ses actes selon les
lois gnement dans lindau ciani on aura
tous réussis pour ton enfant mon petit
enfant est ton arrière petit enfant f à
offida ces fonds d'investissement d'un
niveau mondial permettent d'asseoir ce
projet même si le bon sens fait pencher
la balance
chaque pays reste souverain sachant que
les forces en présence sont nombreuses
la sécurité et la qualité alimentaire
restera clairement le défi de demain
[Musique]